MICHAEL TAFT: Hi.
So this is a talk called
Mindfulness and Emotional
Intelligence, which is largely
out of "The Mindful Geek" book.
OK?
So we'll go into how
mindfulness can help you cope
with emotions in this talk.
It's an iconic moment.
The Rebel Alliance is
making a desperate attack
on the Death Star.
As Luke Skywalker roles
has X-Wing Fighter
in towards the surface
of the battle station,
the voice of Obi
Wan Kenobi speaks
into his head saying,
"Luke trust your feelings."
At first, Luke is
confused, thinking
he must be hearing voices.
But he sees the other pilots
failing to hit the mark.
And at the same
time, Obi Wan keeps
whispering in his ear
saying, "Use the Force
and trust your feelings."
So finally Luke folds away
his targeting computer
and, in fact, uses his
feelings to make the shot.
And as we all know, he
scores a hole in one,
destroying the Empire's
shiny new weapon.
Thus, the timeless
wisdom of "Star Wars"
teaches us that trusting our
feelings is a good thing.
But is that really true?
And what does it even mean
to trust your feelings?
And how can you know
what you're feeling
and what those feelings signify?
In this talk we'll
look at emotions,
emotional intelligence, and
how mindfulness meditation can
help you cope much more
effectively with your feelings
in order to get
more out of life.
Along the way you'll learn
why meditation won't turn you
into a Teletubbie, how sitting
alone in your room meditating
can actually make you more
adept in social situations,
and how Botox injections can
actually reduce your ability
to connect with other people.
And we'll do this from
a perspective that
is interested in and
grounded by science, what I
would call a geeky perspective.
So as Van mentioned, my
name is Michael Taft.
And I got into
meditation early in life.
When I was a teenager,
I was experiencing
debilitating anxiety,
super bad anxiety attacks.
The kind where you sometimes
can't even leave your room.
And I didn't really know
what to do about it.
And there wasn't any help
available that I could find.
But I had read
some books and they
said that there was this
thing called meditation
and that it could help you
to relax and calm down.
And so even though I
didn't have a teacher
and they didn't really describe
very much how to do it,
I just gave it a try on my own.
And voila, it helped me
to feel better right away.
So after that I was hooked.
And I've been meditating for
more than 35 years since then.
I've sat in both Buddhist
and Hindu traditions
all around Asia in monasteries
and temples and retreat
centers, and learned from
some of the greatest teachers
there are.
And although I have
all this experience
in religious traditions
around meditation,
I recently published a book
entitled "The Mindful Geek,"
which is all about learning
mindfulness meditation
in a completely secular,
non-religious and
scientifically-oriented way.
So how'd I get from A to B?
From reciting mantras in Indian
temple caves to penning a book
that's loaded with,
like, research and "Star
Wars" references?
It really began
in the 2000s, when
I was working with
the Bauman Foundation
to write books and create the
Being Human initiative-- you
may have seen the big
conferences that we did
in San Francisco--
and to do other fun
and fascinating projects.
And a big part of that work was
to go meet with neuroscientists
and psychologists in their labs
and to talk with scientists
and philosophers, and
just looking into tons
of research for many years.
And the result after decades
of that, doing meditation,
the result was that
I was compelled
to reevaluate the entire
field of meditation
in the light of all this
cutting-edge science.
The good news is that
the value of meditation
held up quite well
under this scrutiny.
The better news is that the
research contributed vastly
to my understanding of how
meditation actually functions
and what types of meditation
are most effective for what
outcomes we're
looking for, and how
meditation can be
taught in entirely
new and innovative ways.
So it really completely
revolutionized
my viewpoint of what's
going on in meditation
and how we approach
the whole field.
I realize that for many
people, the spiritual context
of meditation-- with
beliefs and hierarchies
and maybe claims--
was something that
was getting in the
way of them being
interested in learning it.
Lots of people who are modern
and secular and scientifically
oriented just don't relate to
that way of thinking at all.
And it became
stunningly clear to me
that meditation, and
especially mindfulness,
is something that can
be taught perfectly well
outside of a spiritual context.
For those interested in
the spiritual context,
that will always be there.
That's available for
anyone who wants it.
But for those who are turned
off by that sort of thing,
there's a different
way of learning
that is not only possible but
which actually, in my opinion,
offers a large
number of advantages.
So that's how I ended up writing
a book called "The Mindful
Geek," and ended up
here talking you to you
today at Google, about
mindfulness, meditation
and emotions.
So just to bring
everybody up to speed,
let's define what we're
actually talking about.
What is mindfulness?
Well, the classic standard
card-carrying mindfulness
teacher definition that
we all have to know
comes from a giant in the
field named Jon Kabat-Zinn.
He was the first guy that
began to introduce mindfulness
into the medical community.
And to do this, he had to dress
like the MIT-trained professor
of medicine that he is.
Up until that point
in American history--
and we're talking
about, essentially,
the mid '80s--
meditaters were seen
as hippies with long
beards and long robes
and long strings of beads
and people who are chanting
and with candles and incense.
And I used to be
one of those people.
I like those people.
And then along comes
Jon Kabat-Zinn.
And he's sitting there
in a three-piece suit
with a haircut and a neck tie.
And it just kind of
blew everybody's mind.
Because it was so different
than what we had seen before,
what anyone had done before.
It was totally different
than the cultural image
of a meditater.
And as part of his drive to
bring this mindfulness practice
into hospitals, into
the medical community,
he had to come up with a really
concise and precise definition.
And it's pretty
different than the way it
had been talked about before.
And his definition
goes like this.
"Mindfulness is paying
attention on purpose,
in the present moment,
nonjudgmentally,
to the unfolding of
experience moment by moment."
So it's a pretty
complicated definition.
So I'll just say
it one more time.
"Mindfulness is paying
attention on purpose,
in the present moment,
nonjudgmentally,
to the unfolding of
experience moment to moment."
So this has become the
standard one-line definition
that every mindfulness
teacher is forced to memorize.
Or the mindfulness police
come and you take away
your meditation cushion.
You just, like, have to be able
to reel that off from memory.
And if you want to know the
difference between mindfulness
and meditation, the
answer is simply
that mindfulness is
a kind of meditation.
So it's a subset of
the greater field
of meditation practice, which
includes a lot of other things.
So what about all this
emotional intelligence
stuff that I was
saying we'd talk about?
Well, mindfulness meditation
has been proven over and over
to enhance your life in a
whole bunch of different ways.
This is all the research
I keep talking about.
It's been shown that if
you practice regularly,
you can expect improvement in
areas such as concentration,
creativity, memory retention,
reduce stress, and a lot more
than that.
But for my money,
probably the most powerful
and interesting and
useful and life-changing
way that mindfulness can
improve your well being
is in the realm of emotions.
This is where it really, really
starts to change your life.
It's funny, but
emotions or "feelings"--
in the words of Obi Wan--
are maybe humanity's biggest
problem.
We're destroying the
planet because we can't
handle our feelings of greed.
We cause havoc and murder
and destruction with war
because we can't handle our
feelings of fear and hatred.
But it's more personal
than that too.
Virtually everything
you do every day,
you do in order to
feel good emotionally.
You're just trying to make
your feelings feel good.
You date your partner to
be in a relationship that
makes you feel good.
You work out so you'll lose
weight and not feel bad.
You earn money in order to
not feel afraid of starving
or to feel happy about
the shiny products you
line your nest with, and so on.
So emotions rule your life.
And based on that fact alone,
understanding the background
and function of emotions is
clearly of supreme importance.
The clearer picture you
have of your emotions
the clearer picture you
have of your entire life.
And mindfulness meditation
is a very effective method
for getting clarity and
insight about your emotions
and enhancing your emotional
skills dramatically.
Or to put it in
the current jargon,
mindfulness boosts your
emotional intelligence.
So I say that a lot
to people, mindfulness
boosts your emotional
intelligence.
And what people hear
me say is something
like mindfulness will make
you happy all the time.
But that's not what I'm saying.
Rest assured,
mindfulness will not
make you happy all the time.
The practice will greatly
increase your well being
and enhance your
life in many ways.
But it won't make you
happy every minute.
It won't turn you
into a Teletubbie,
dancing without a care in the
world or a thought in its head.
No matter what's going on,
everything's just great.
Instead, mindfulness
will allow you
to feel your feelings with
much greater sensitivity,
and also cope with those
feelings much more effectively.
It's not about so
much changing them
as changing your
relationship to them.
But let's get a little more
fundamental here, go back
to first principles.
And ask the question, what are
emotions in the first place?
Where did we get them
and what are they for?
Well, evolution created emotions
in animals as guidance systems.
Emotions are
mechanisms that tell
you what to do in order
to stay fed, safe,
and to spread your genes
into the next generations.
So just for example, fear makes
total sense in this context.
It's like, hey, that one
watering hole over there,
over the next hill,
always has a lot
of predators lurking around it.
So let's stay away from that.
Right?
We're afraid of
that watering hole.
Because that's a bad place.
Or anger turns on when you're
cornered and you can't get away
and you have to
fight your way out.
Angers evolve for
situations like that.
So this is how emotions
are guidance systems.
They're there to
motivate and direct
your behavior, what to do next.
So emotions in
human beings evolved
to do something very similar.
They act as a behavioral
guidance system for our lives.
Or at least that's
what they're ideally
meant to do in an
ancient ancestor of ours
living in a small group on a
savanna a million years ago.
They're a little
out of date now.
And many of our reactions
don't make perfect sense
in a modern environment.
One example is the fact that
almost throughout almost all
of human and pre-human
history, a person
lived in a tiny band of
maybe 25 to 50 people.
So you just saw the
same 35 faces day in
and day out for
your entire life.
Meeting new people,
especially unexpectedly,
was almost always
a really bad thing.
So we contend to get triggered
and anxious around strangers.
Because our biology
was evolved to tell us
that strangers are bad.
And yet, today, if you go
for a little stroll down
the street in New York City,
or sit in a baseball stadium
anywhere, you can find
yourself surrounded
by thousands and thousands of
faces you've never seen before,
instantly.
So this produces anxiety
because of the hard wiring
of our brain, which
tells us to get worried
when strangers are present.
So that's just one
of the many ways
their our emotional guidance
system is a little out of date
and needs some help.
For example, with
mindfulness meditation
to cope with our
current environment.
So the thing about
a guidance system
is it works best if it has both
negative and positive feedback.
So you have to have both
positive and negative.
I mean, imagine a
compass needle that's
only stuck in one place
or a maps application
on your phone that just
told you to turn right
at every intersection.
It wouldn't work, obviously.
You need both a North and a
South, a right and a left,
for a guidance system
to function optimally.
And the same thing is true of
your emotional guidance system.
It won't work unless it has
both the positive emotions
and negative emotions with which
to motivate and direct you.
There's certain things that
you shouldn't do or shouldn't
do again.
You should know
that they're bad.
So it's like do
this, don't do that,
is what emotions are
trying to tell you.
So you need both of
them if the system
is going to function properly.
And so having a
clear understanding
that both positive and
negative emotions are
natural and adaptive
and useful will
go a long way towards
both understanding
why you're feeling something.
But more importantly, to
cope with what you're feeling
and accept it, which
is what mindfulness
is going to help you to do.
And again, when I
tell people this,
there's this sense of like,
you know, that's fine.
And that makes sense.
And I understand
the evolution of it.
But really, I just want to
feel happy all the time.
Can't we do that?
But honestly, even
if you could do that,
even if you can feel
happy every minute,
you actually wouldn't like it.
It would be a bad thing.
And just for example,
there are people
born with a gene that makes
it impossible to feel pain.
Wouldn't that be great?
Wouldn't you like that?
You'd never feel pain.
It sounds great.
But these people who literally
can't feel anything negative
have very serious
difficulties in life.
They're constantly
injuring themselves
and breaking their
limbs and burning
their skin and other things.
And they never know it.
They only find out when
they see it or someone else
tells them it's going on.
And so even the tiniest things
are tremendously dangerous.
And so most people who
have this condition-- which
is known as congenital
insensitivity
to pain with anhydrous--
don't live long lives.
It's just too dangerous
to never feel any pain.
And so with emotions,
it's something similar.
Just like pleasure and pain
are a kind of guidance system,
positive and negative
emotions are a similar sort
of guidance system.
And in human
beings, the activity
of that guidance
system, your emotions,
is called decision making.
And all of us have a lot of
decisions to make each day.
And it turns out that our
ability to feel these emotions
are central to that process
of making decisions.
That's right.
We use our emotions
to make decisions.
We know this to be
true because there
are certain unfortunate
individuals who,
either through
disease or injury,
lose the parts of
their brain that
allows them to feel emotions.
So we have examples of
people who never feel any.
And one of these
people is referred
to in the medical
literature simply
as "Elliot," like
it's a pseudonym.
He had lost parts of
his prefrontal cortex
by having a brain tumor removed.
And afterwards, he
seemed completely normal.
He was super intelligent.
And he was charming.
And he was well informed.
But he had lost this connection
to his emotional guidance
system.
And had lost, therefore, the
ability to make good decisions.
He'd agonize endlessly over,
like, what TV show to watch.
He couldn't decide.
And then sometimes
rush headlong and half
cocked into these big
important life decisions.
And so he lost his job.
And he lost all
his money by making
these crazy financial
speculations
and eighty-sixed his marriage.
And his children went away.
And eventually, due to the
loss of his emotional guidance
system, his life was ruined.
And this is actually
typical for people who
have this kind of brain damage.
They're completely brilliant.
They have all the
logical, rational ability
that you think would allow
them to make decisions.
But because they can't contact
their emotional guidance system
nothing works right.
So in the prefrontal
cortex-- which
is the part that
Elliott had removed--
connects many different
areas of the brain,
including those that are
concerned with reasoning,
to those that are
concerned with sensing,
the feeling state of the body.
So it's like a place where
the reasoning and the feeling
come together.
And so when human beings
go about making a decision
they do the reasoning part,
collecting all the data
about the subject, all this
kind of external, concrete,
cost-benefit-analysis
type stuff.
But that's not the whole story.
We also consult physical
somatic memories
of our past emotional states.
Noticing how we felt
as the result of making
similar decisions in the past.
How did I feel last time
I did something like that?
And most or all of
this consideration
goes on underneath
conscious awareness.
But eventually, the process
gives rise to the feeling
that one of the choices
is better than the rest.
And noticing this
requires the ability
to sense the
feelings in your body
and to coordinate
those sensations
with the
decision-making function
of your prefrontal cortex.
So you're doing this, like,
how did that feel last time?
Sort of thing.
And you have to be able to
feel your feelings to do that.
So for most of us that
goes on under the hood.
But the gist of all
this is that emotions
are central to us
making good decisions.
And as such, we
might like to imagine
that we're completely calm
and Spock-like in our choices,
totally rational and analytical.
But this is literally
almost never the case.
Although economic theory
asserts that human beings are
the sorts of rational actors,
studies have shown repeatedly
that we are anything but that.
And somewhere under
the hood, our emotions
are playing a key role in every
single decision that we make.
So a writer and a neuroscientist
that I really like,
Antonio Damasio, calls
his idea about how
this works the "Somatic
Marker Hypothesis," or SMH.
To understand the
SMH, you first have
to understand that emotions
are primarily somatic events.
You know you're having
an emotion because you're
feeling it in your body.
And this idea is usually a
little weird for Westerners
to accept.
Because after 50 years of
behavioral and cognitive
psychology, we have
this idea that emotions
are mental events.
Like, we think about emotions.
And it's true that the brain
is in charge of deciding,
for example, that we should
be afraid if we see a train
or whatever.
But it's usually making
that decision far
below the level of
conscious awareness.
And more importantly, once
it makes that decision,
like, hey it's
time to be afraid.
Then that triggers a whole
series of changes in the body,
like a faster heart rate
and faster breathing
and sweaty palms.
And your muscles in your legs
get all pumped up and energized
and ready to run, and so on.
And these characterize the
feeling of being afraid.
So even though emotions
may be orchestrated
in the deep unconscious,
it's upon the soma.
It's upon your physical
body that their symphony
is played out.
Right?
So the brain decides
it's time to be afraid.
But then the body
is the expression.
And one of the ways that
we can understand that
is that our emotional
responses evolved
from similar emotional
responses in animals.
Who, presumably, aren't
making a whole bunch
of long, logical, rational,
cognitive decisions
about emotions.
It's something you
feel that motivates
you to behave in a certain way.
So trying an experiment
with me right now.
It's going to make you
a little uncomfortable.
I want you to think
about all the things
that make you anxious.
Whatever you're most worried
about in the world right now,
really bring your fears to mind.
And if you want me to
just help you with this,
you can think about global
warming and rising income
inequality and the fact that
a reality TV star could soon
be our president.
And you could throw
in the knowledge
that you're going
to die someday.
Just actually get yourself
worked up over your fears.
Please do that for me right now.
We won't do it for long.
But to do this well, you
actually have to try.
And so do this for a moment
till you notice you're
feeling a little bit anxious.
OK.
So raise your hand
if you actually
notice that thinking
about that stuff
is making you
slightly revved up.
A couple people?
OK.
Good.
Then ask yourself how do
you know you're anxious?
What do you feel in your body?
Is your stomach area tight?
Or maybe you feel a little
nausea or your chest
could feel tighter or your
breathing has sped up.
What sensations?
So just close your
eyes and explore.
What sensations in your
body feel like the feelings
of anxiety to you?
It's OK if you're not sure.
Just notice whatever you notice.
And remember that.
And then the next time you get
anxious at home or at work,
or out in the world or whatever,
tune into your body again.
And see if the
anxiety is expressing
with those same sensations
that you noticed just now.
It's a lot easier when
you're not making it up.
Out there, and you notice
you're feeling real anxiety,
check it out.
But see if they're
the same sensations.
But of course, I'm
not going to leave you
all revved up and anxious.
So let's go ahead
and do the opposite.
So again, this time, think
of the people and animals
that you love the most, somebody
that you really care about.
And see them in your mind's
eye having the greatest
day of their life,
feeling super happy
and doing things
they really enjoy.
And picture them
laughing and joyous.
So really do this right now, OK?
Close your eyes
and picture this.
And just see them having a
great time in your imagination.
And picture it as clearly
as you can over and over.
See them smiling and happy
and just having a great time.
And do this until you notice
that you feel just a little bit
of happiness somehow.
And raise your hand if you
feel just a tiny bit happy.
OK.
Now, ask yourself, how do you
know you're feeling happy?
How do you know?
Where are you sensing
it in your body?
Maybe you notice some
activation in the muscles
around your mouth and cheeks,
kind of a ghost of a smile.
You might not
actually be smiling.
But you start to feel that
it might want to do that.
Or you can feel the
sensation of like, upliftment
or rising in your
chest, or like,
your heart expanding if
the happiness gets big.
But you feel it in
your actual chest.
So these are some of the
body sensations of happiness.
And hopefully they replaced
any sensations of anxiety
we brought up.
And the next time you get
slammed with happiness
out there in the
world, remind yourself
to contact these sensations
of happiness in your body.
And notice that the
details of what it feels
like, physically, to feel happy.
And just take a moment
when you do that to, like,
enjoy and relish
those sensations.
Like, allow yourself to
really experience the pleasure
of happiness in your body.
So what we just did right
there is a mindfulness
of emotions exercise.
It's a very typical
exercise of beginning
to notice the sensations
in your body of emotions.
And there are a
lot of other ones.
The one thing to
get out of it is
that the experience
of your emotions
is largely in your body.
You may have thoughts
about an emotion.
But the emotion itself
is in the flesh.
So then, going back to the
Somatic Marker Hypothesis--
remember it says, somatic, which
means embodied-- Damasio says
that the brain uses
these emotional body
sensations like the ones
you were just feeling.
And it uses those to assist
it in making decisions.
Those are the somatic markers.
When you're trying
to make the decision,
you unconsciously
recall memories
of previous similar situations
and remember those feelings
that you had in your
body about the outcome.
And as an example,
imagine that you're
trying to decide whether to
buy a lottery ticket or not.
Which, rationally,
is always a bad idea.
You may feel very excited
about the possibility
of winning-- like, wow, I could
win-- since the jackpot happens
to be unusually huge this month.
Yet consciously or
not, you also remember
how you felt--
disappointed and downcast--
in your previous attempts
at buying lottery tickets.
You're remembering those
feelings in your body.
And those emotional tones
serve as somatic markers
that guide you away.
Remember, it's a
guidance system.
Those remembered feelings of
like, wow, last time I bought
those tickets I felt bad.
That guides you away from
buying a ticket this time.
So that's how
somatic markers work.
And that's how
emotions guide you.
So researchers devised
a fascinating experiment
to test the Somatic
Marker Hypothesis.
They created a game involving
four decks of cards.
And the participants in
the game were given money
by the researcher.
So they all start out
with a pile of money.
And each of the decks
are made of cards
that either take
money from your pile
or give you more
money into your pile.
And so two of the decks
were completely random.
They had an equal
number of cards
that took away money and
cards that gave you money.
So they were fair.
Those were fair decks.
But secretly, the
other two decks we're
rigged to have a lot
more negative cards.
They were cards that
would steal your money.
They were totally unfair.
And this meant that
those decks were "bad."
And so they have
these participants
play this game, where they're
taking cards and giving cards
back.
And it turns out that
healthy participants
began noticing that those
unfair decks were unfair,
after about 40 turns.
It took them about 40
turns to figure out
that those decks weren't random.
And they just would never
choose from them again.
But intriguingly, their bodies
showed measurable stress
after only 10 turns.
So in body sensation
terms, they already
knew they were bad
after only 10 turns,
suggesting that their
unconscious brain was
already aware that the
decks were no good.
And in fact, if they were better
at feeling their own feelings--
like you'd get from
mindfulness meditation--
they would have stopped drawing
the bad cards a lot earlier.
Because sensing the body
sensations of emotions
is how intuition works.
But what's interesting
is people with damage
to the prefrontal cortex,
these people who couldn't feel
their emotions, just kept
drawing from the bad decks
for the whole game.
They never stopped.
They never caught on.
So they went bankrupt.
And they had to
beg the researchers
for additional funds
to keep playing.
And they never had
a stress response.
You know, hooked up
to the same machinery,
their bodies didn't know
that the game was bad.
So they couldn't
feel their emotions.
They couldn't make
good decisions.
So feeling our emotions is a
big deal in having a good life.
So this biological and
evolutionary background
of emotions leads us
to one big conclusion.
It's a good idea to
feel your feelings
and accept them just
the way they are.
Remember that official
definition of mindfulness?
That I already said
twice out loud,
I'll say it one more time.
"Mindfulness is paying
attention on purpose,
in the present moment,
nonjudgmentally,
to the unfolding of
experience moment to moment."
So you might notice it includes
that word, nonjudgmentally.
And that means, in this
case, accepting your emotions
just the way they are.
And it helps if
you will recognize
that human emotions
are responses
that were programmed into
our biology over millions
and millions of years.
We like to think
that our emotions are
personal and intimate and
special things about us.
And this is the Doctor McCoy
theory of human existence.
We're always hearing "Bones"
passionately assert something
about the value of
squishy human feelings
in the face of cold,
rational logic.
But seen from an
evolutionary perspective,
our emotions are a
little bit mechanistic.
And sure, the reasons you
have for your emotions
are very unique.
And human beings are so complex
that our emotional responses
are very unpredictable
and individual.
But the emotional
responses themselves
are not necessarily "yours,"
as much as they are a reaction.
And recognizing that is really
helpful in coping with them.
Admitting this means that
you can stop taking so much
personal responsibility
for every little thing
that you're feeling, which
is usually a big relief.
Not every emotion you're having
is one that you consciously
decided to have.
Despite what all the new-age
memes in your Facebook feed
are telling you, you
don't have total control
over your feelings.
Taking personal responsibility
for each emotion
makes about as much sense as
taking personal responsibility
for your liver function.
Instead, accept that you're
feeling however you're feeling.
If you want to change that
later, you can try to do that.
And you don't have to
express that feeling
or do anything about it.
And if you want to
change the feeling later,
you can try to do that too.
But beating yourself up for
how you're feeling emotionally
at any moment is very
counterproductive.
And it just doesn't work.
The system is doing
what it's doing.
And in mindfulness we
want to remember that.
And particularly, feeling
bad doesn't always
mean that there's
something wrong.
You might have perfectly
good reasons for feeling bad.
As a society, we're really
intolerant for the presence
of unpleasant emotions.
Sorrow or anything like that,
we don't like having it.
And we rush to fix
it or change it
immediately even when the
emotion makes perfect sense.
So for example, some
people take antidepressants
after the death of a loved one.
Because the grief
can be so intense.
And I'm not judging
that one way or another.
And during the recent
updating of the DSM-IV-- which
is the Diagnostical
and Statistical Manual
that psychiatrists use
to diagnose patients--
the committee in charge of
that wanted to categorize grief
as a mental illness.
So just feeling bad about
somebody dying and feeling
grief, they were to say,
well, that's mental illness.
Why?
Because it feels bad.
People don't like it.
And so you know, this suggestion
was vetoed, thankfully.
They didn't end up putting that
in there as a mental illness.
And you know, it's true.
Grief feels really unpleasant.
But wouldn't it be strange
to respond to, for example,
the death of a loved
one by feeling happy
or nothing at all?
It's a natural response.
So when you see emotions
in the light of acceptance,
you can begin to have an
entirely different relationship
to them.
You begin to understand
that they are simply
happening, like your
heartbeat or your breathing.
And a full range of
emotions, including
positive and negative,
indicates that you're
a healthy, functioning organism.
Your emotions are there
to guide your behavior,
not to make you feel good.
So now, I just have to make
a little public service
announcement.
Because people can
take this too far.
If you're experiencing something
like clinical depression
or a clinical anxiety
disorder, taking
a psycho-pharmacological
medication
could be an important
step in your return
to well being, not
just acceptance.
Getting your emotional system in
good working order is crucial.
And sometimes the
process requires
things like medicine
and psychotherapy
and other end of interventions,
before you kind of get back
on track.
So in mindfulness
meditation, you
learn to accept your emotions.
You don't have to like them.
And you don't have to want them.
But you will have a much
better experience each day
by letting them just be the way
they are and not fighting it.
If you do this day in and day
out, both in formal practice
and in life, after
a while you'll
notice something really,
really interesting happening.
It's really worth it.
So probably many of you
have heard this quote.
But Viktor Frankl, the
neurologist and psychologist
who was a survivor
of Auschwitz--
the most egregious
concentration camp of them
all-- once wrote that
"Between stimulus and response
there's a space.
And in that space is our
power to choose our response.
In our response lies our
growth and our freedom."
So this brilliant
quote points to one
of the deepest and most
important benefits derived
from mindfulness of emotions.
And that is it increases
your behavioral flexibility.
It gives you more choices
about your response.
Human beings display
a surprising amount
of automaticity in our behavior.
That is, under the
same conditions
we tend to do the same
things over and over again.
Stimulus, response,
stimulus, response.
Same conditions, same response.
And I know what you're
thinking, which is that that's
the definition of insanity.
But really, it's just
part of being human.
Regardless of
whether the behavior
is effective or
desirable or not,
we automatically
repeat it with a kind
of mechanical predictability.
To put it in
Frankl's terms, there
isn't any distance between
the stimulus and the response.
We just feel the
feeling and then act.
And if you do
that, you just keep
getting the same
result every time,
under the same conditions.
So earlier we did a body
sensation meditation.
But you can go deeper
and just meditate
on emotional-type
body sensations,
like that feeling in
your face of being happy
or some of those
feelings of anxiety.
By meditating in that way,
with an emphasis on accepting
the feelings however they are,
does something really cool.
Which is it builds a
gap where the "space"--
that Frankl's talking about--
between the stimulus--
which is the emotion--
and the response--
which is what you do
about the emotion.
So there's a gap in there.
And by cultivating
this space, you
gain something every human
being ever born has wanted,
which is the ability to
choose whether to respond
to this emotional urge or not.
And if you do decide
to respond, you
can choose how you
want to respond.
It's not just a
reaction anymore.
The emotions themselves
haven't changed.
You're accepting
however you feel.
You're not, like, submerging
yourself in a sea of bliss.
It's not all happy,
happy, joy, joy.
Instead you're going to feel
your emotions very keenly.
But you develop the
ability to not act on them
if you don't want to.
Because you cultivate
this kind of acceptance.
And this can save you,
and those around you,
a lot of trouble and pain.
Think of all the times
you've done something rash
and regretted it afterwards.
Like you've said something
out of rage or spite
that should never
have been spoken.
Think of all the urges or
compulsions or even addictions
that you automatically
respond to,
even when you don't want to.
You know they're bad.
But the feeling comes
up and you just do it.
Mindfulness of
emotion allows you
to gain some measure
of control over that,
and maybe even a kind
of wisdom, with respect
to the expression
of these emotions.
You're able to respond
intelligently rather than
simply react.
So it's interesting.
Because, like, ancient
philosophers and theologians
from every culture were
almost uniformly negative
about emotions, which
they called something
like "the passions."
And it's because of this
feature that human beings
can do something
terrible and irreversible
in a moment of
emotional intensity
and then regret it for
the rest of their lives
and cause a lot of damage.
But meditation on emotion,
mindfulness of emotion,
can help you to make sure that
you think before you act and do
the intelligent thing.
And you should check out
the groundbreaking addiction
research and treatments
done by my friend,
Judson Brewer-- he's an
Ph.D, M.D. From Yale--
If you want to learn
more about the power
of this way of working.
Because the kind of
results you could
get from meditating on, say,
urges of addiction or emotional
urges is amazing.
It's getting amazing results
in double-blind studies.
OK.
So once you're accepting the
emotions that you're feeling,
but not necessarily acting
upon them, what next?
How can you use that
time between the stimulus
and the response?
Between the time you
start feeling the emotion
in your body and the time
you do something about it?
The answer is you can
meditate upon the body
sensation of the emotion with
as much clarity as possible.
You want to have clarity.
And what do I mean by clarity?
Well, you can
think of meditation
as a kind of
awareness-extending technology,
like a telescope
or a microscope.
When you begin the
practice of mindfulness
you're training your
awareness on present moment
sensory experiences.
And at first, that'll
feel pretty normal.
But after a while, you notice
an increase in your ability
to detect finer and finer
qualities of sensation
at smaller and smaller scales.
Your brain just gets
better at detecting
the different sensations in
nearby areas of the body.
This aspect of meditation
is called sensory clarity,
where you use your
awareness like a telescope
or a microscope to "see"
smaller and subtler
sensory experiences.
Sensory clarity takes
a while to develop.
And it requires that
you attempt to make
these really fine distinctions
in your meditation practice.
So it's not just about
feeling your body.
It's about getting
good at feeling
the details of your body.
For example, if I asked
you to concentrate
on the bodily sensations
currently present
in your right foot--
which we did earlier.
So do that now.
Feel your right foot--
what do you feel?
Most people, with no
mindfulness training,
report basically feeling
their entire foot.
It's as if the
sensations can only
be experienced as a few
big pixels of information.
It's just a foot.
Because we're not
used to zeroing in.
Or maybe you have a little
efficacy or a little clarity.
And you might call it
"sensory resolution."
Maybe you have a
little resolution
on your body sensation.
And you can feel
for nine big pixels
of feeling there, feeling
data in your foot.
But with mindfulness
practice, the resolution
of the sensory data in your
foot can get a lot bigger,
like 128 pixels of
feeling in your foot.
And eventually-- and it
won't take that long,
like six months-- you'll
be able to effortlessly
feel pixels as small
as a grain of sand
everywhere in your foot.
The surface, inside,
all through it,
you can just pick out each
little spot individually.
And you can just
take my word for it.
But there's science about this.
One study found that
meditaters were not only able
to focus much better
than controls--
this is after only
four days of practice--
but that they increased
the depth of "information
processing" on their
body sensation as well.
And that's what
I'm talking about,
the depth of
information processing.
So there's more
pixels of data there.
Another study focusing
on tactile sensations
looked at a number of objective
and subjective measures
of sensitivity in
experienced meditaters.
And they found that
the measured area
of the cortex of their brain
dedicated to tactile sensation
was bigger.
The researchers found
that meditation enhances
introspective accuracy
for bodily sensations,
meaning that the
practitioners don't just
think they have greater
sensation or greater
sensory clarity
than non-meditaters.
They actually have much more
resources, much more neurons
dedicated to the task
of body sensations
than people who don't meditate.
So you grow this really
high-quality sensory
resolution.
And it doesn't have
to be just your body.
It can be on all your
other senses also.
So in the case of
emotions, you learn
to be very precise and detailed
and specific with regards
to emotional body sensations.
Meditating on
emotions in the body
will develop the part
of your brain called
the insula, which is the
part of the brain associated
with the feeling of
internal sensations.
And doing this will
help you get better
at noticing these fine
degrees of sensation,
which my teacher, Shinzen
Young, calls "skill at feeling."
Skill at feeling has a
number of important benefits.
One is that it will allow
you to know more about how
you're feeling.
Many people have a difficult
time describing or even knowing
what emotions they're
actually having right now.
It's not so much a
lack of vocabulary,
but a lack of the ability to
contact emotional sensations
with clarity.
They just know they're
feeling something.
But by developing the skill at
feeling through mindfulness,
you'll have a much better idea
of what you're experiencing
emotionally, moment by moment.
And given that these
little feelings
are so important
in decision making,
like, remember that
game where people
could have chosen the cards
instead of after 40 turns,
after only 10 turns, presumably,
if they had been able to feel
their emotions better.
It's a really important
thing to be able to do.
So it's clearly very helpful.
And it's almost like
growing better and better
at having intuition.
But there's even
more to it than that.
There are even bigger
and better benefits
to practicing
mindfulness of emotions.
You know, it's funny.
When you tell your
friends that you're
going to spend the next 10
minutes or 30 minutes off
in your room, meditating,
if they're cool
they'll be supportive.
But I've often heard
people say that it's
a "selfish" thing to do.
Or that meditation like
that is self indulgent.
And you know, I can see
why they would think that.
You're sitting
alone in your room,
paying close attention to your
body sensations, for example.
And that can sound
like a really sort
of precious and
self-absorbed activity.
But the really
fascinating thing is
this-- sitting
alone in your room,
meditating on your feelings
of emotions in your body,
can actually make
you better at knowing
what other people are feeling.
And that, of course,
is the opposite
of being self-absorbed.
It can actually make
you much more empathic.
It turns out that human beings
tune into other people's
feelings by subtly
mimicking the other person's
expressions in their own faces.
And these are known
as micro expressions.
These are just very tiny,
almost unconscious versions
of normal expressions.
So if the person across
from you has a big smile,
you have this micro
expression smile
that can't be seen
with a camera,
but can be detected
with electrodes.
And that's just part of our
built-in evolutionary mechanism
that helps us cooperate with
a group of other people, which
is what we evolved to do.
Meditating on
emotional sensations
begins to slowly
make these feelings
of these micro expressions
a lot more noticeable.
So most of the time, they're
going on unconsciously.
You're making these
micro expressions
to understand other
people's feelings.
But you don't really
know you're doing it.
But meditating on them
makes it so you can
feel those micro expressions.
And that's a crucial skill
for deepening connection
with other people.
And that builds
better relationships.
You just get better at people.
Again, there's some
really compelling evidence
to show that this is the case.
So how can we actually
prove that people really
do get this empathic
information from mimicking
others' expressions?
Most of us aren't even
aware that we're doing it.
So self reports wouldn't help.
What if we could somehow
freeze people's facial muscles
so they were actually physically
prevented from mimicking
others?
Is there a population of
people readily available
who have frozen facial muscles?
Yes.
And they're called people
who get Botox injections.
So researchers
Neil and Chartrand
gave a standard empathy
test to a group of women who
had received Botox injections.
The test involves looking
at pictures of people's eyes
and then determining what
emotion they're feeling.
So you look at all these
different pictures of eyes.
And you're like,
this person scared
or this person's
happy, whatever.
And then they
compared these results
to another group of women
who had gotten injections
of a dermal filler, which is
another kind of cosmetic thing.
But it doesn't impair your
muscles, your facial muscles.
And it's clever.
Because that group of
women were very similar
in terms of age
and income and all
these other
demographic features.
So the groups were
really similar,
except one group's facial
muscles were frozen
and the other's weren't.
The result was that the
Botox women were greatly
reduced in their ability
to empathize with others.
They couldn't guess properly
what other people were feeling.
And it's because they couldn't
move their own facial muscles
and couldn't tune into
their own micro expressions.
So they lost this
ability to connect.
And so just to prove
the point, to make
sure this wasn't some
statistical anomaly
or something, the
researchers did something
that I thought was really cool.
Which is they did the
entire experiment again.
But this time, instead
of the Botox group,
they gave a group of women
a kind of stiffening gel
on their face.
It made their skin really stiff.
And all that did was make
their muscles work a lot harder
to move.
They didn't freeze the
muscles or stop them.
But they made it harder to move.
And because the muscles
had to work harder,
it made those micro
expressions easier to feel.
That's the important part.
They could feel the
micro expressions.
And as expected, those
women got much higher scores
on the empathy test than the
people with the dermal filler.
So mindfulness does something
very similar to this stiffening
gel.
Over time, your
insula-- which is
the thing that allows you to
feel your body-- gets bigger.
And so your ability to feel
these micro expressions
gets heightened.
And because you can
feel it more clearly,
you can tune to other people
are much more effectively.
And that's how sitting
alone in your room
can make you more empathic
and even do better
in your relationships
and social situations.
So these are the basics
behind using mindfulness
to increase your
emotional intelligence.
You accept the emotions
you're feeling.
You notice that those emotions
are embodied experiences.
And you zero in on
the physical details
of each emotional body sensation
with as much clarity as
possible.
"Trust your feelings, Luke."
With daily practice
over time, you'll
notice a positive revolution
in your experience
of your own inner life, your
interactions and relationships
with other people, and even your
satisfaction with existence.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So mostly what
we covered right now
was how the science works.
MICHAEL TAFT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: In terms
of implementation,
do you suggest something
done differently?
So mindfulness
meditation mostly, today,
focuses on the
breath or something
that you can just
pay attention to.
MICHAEL TAFT: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: Given that there is
an emotional context to it now,
is there something else
you suggest or propose?
MICHAEL TAFT: Yes.
So honestly, the
only different thing
is that instead of the emotional
body sensations associated
with breathing, or the emotional
body sensations of a body scan,
you're picking out the
sensations of emotion.
And that's why I had you
do the thing of bringing up
the anxiety or bringing
up the happiness
so that you could learn to feel
what an emotional sensation
feels like.
And then I was saying,
out in the world, when
you have those emotions,
let's say you get really happy
one day.
You're super happy.
Just spend five
minutes or one minute
or even 30 seconds and
tune into the feelings
of the happiness in your body.
So you begin to learn what
an emotion feels like.
But then, after that,
you're doing the same things
that you would do in any
other mindfulness, which
is you accept those feelings
just the way they are.
You don't try to change them.
And as I mentioned,
you zero in really
specifically on the
details of the feeling.
So you would do that in a breath
meditation or a body sensation
meditation anyway, right?
You're going to
accept the feelings.
And you're going to get
into the subtleties.
You want to notice the fine
details, and in this case,
the fine details of
emotions in your body.
That's all it takes.
Because after awhile, you'll
start feeling your feelings,
like, a week before you
would have felt them before,
or 10 minutes before you would
have noticed them before.
And that makes all
the difference.
That's building that gap
between stimulus and response.
Suddenly, it's like, how those
people could have potentially
noticed the bad decks earlier.
Their body was noticing it.
They're having a
stress response.
If you know how to feel a
stress response, than you could,
presumably, notice that
the decks were bad earlier.
So just getting really good
at feeling the feelings
and not trying to change them,
getting into the details,
getting all sensitive,
changes your life.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Are you familiar with
trapped emotions?
And can you give me an
insight in how mindful can
help release a trapped emotion?
MICHAEL TAFT: So
what do you mean
by the term trapped emotion?
AUDIENCE: Trapped
emotion is emotion
that is physically
trapped in the human flesh
by not dealing with it in time.
And over time it
just gets trapped.
I know for a fact that
that's a condition
that we all are affected by.
If you are familiar with that
or not, what you can tell me.
MICHAEL TAFT: Yeah.
What I would say is that
the main thing to do
there is the acceptance piece.
Because for something,
for an emotion
to stay suppressed like
that, or stay trapped,
it has to have a force
keeping it in there.
It's being suppressed in
some way psychologically.
But if you, over time--
through meditation
and through mindfulness--
are reversing
that psychological stance, and
accepting over and over what
you're feeling, it might
be that you don't even
feel that trapped
emotion for a long time.
But then one day, because
you're insula's growing
and you're getting much more
sensitive, much more detailed.
You notice, hey, I'm
feeling something in there.
I'm feeling something in there.
And it might not feel very good.
Right?
There's a reason
you're suppressing it.
It might feel really awful.
But you just keep accepting
it and accepting it.
And eventually, it
will start to express.
It's why you have to have
this stance of acceptance.
Because you want those
kind of suppressed emotions
to express and
then be done with.
Be done with them.
AUDIENCE: So I do
a lot of training
on my team around feedback.
And when I say that
word, everyone's
like, morale just
drops considerably.
It has a very visceral,
emotional response.
And I train them using almost
the exact same technique
that you did
around, like, almost
like immunizing yourself.
So I'm going to
purposely apply pressure
so that you can feel what
this feels like, to get
like the worst possible news.
So if you see it again
you won't feel as bad.
MICHAEL TAFT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any other suggestions
I can give my teammates
when I train them
on this kind of
behavioral response?
MICHAEL TAFT: Suggestions
for making it--
AUDIENCE: I guess, bearable?
Tolerable.
It's a painful process,
especially here.
Feedback can be really intense.
MICHAEL TAFT: Right.
So I'm sure, as
you already know,
starting out with small emotions
is better than starting out
with big ones.
Right?
Little tiny discomforts,
emotionally,
are much easier to work with.
The other one is-- and I
mean, this is not necessarily
making it easier--
but you know, it's
different in your
lab or your office
than it is out in the world.
And so it's something
you can give them
on the first day is
just to say, hey,
we're not going to trigger
you emotionally here.
But between the
time you see me now
and the time you see me next,
when something triggers you
and you feel bad emotionally,
here's what you do.
So that it's allowing
the world to give them
the difficult experience.
But now you've
given them the way
to work with it, to
begin working with it.
And then when they come
back the next to the office,
they have material that you've
already given them a tool
to help them cope with that
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
MICHAEL TAFT: So thank
you all very much.
And hope to speak to you again.
[APPLAUSE]